Huge oral argument just now in the
United States Court of Appeals for the
Second Circuit in New York City over
whether or not stun guns, that's right,
non-lethal stun guns are protected arms
under the Second Amendment. This should
be a layup case in light of the 2016
Supreme Court decision in Kitano versus
Massachusetts. But is it? Well, we're
going to break it all down, including
with two judges that I'm friendly with
on the Second Circuit. Let's chat about
it when we come right back.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
four box of Diner, proud American gun
owner, constitutional attorney, member
of the United States Supreme Court Bar,
and I'm proud to say the top voice of
the Second Amendment in America. Thank
you. 2025 and 2026 Gundy's awards. All
right, folks. So again, just as a
reminder, on Friday night, I'll be the
keynote speaker at the Gun Owners of
America Activist Dinner. So, if you're
going to be out there in Arizona, please
feel free and stop by and say hello and
we'll talk about the Second Amendment
and more. Okay. So, we just had an oral
argument in New York City in the case of
Calcy versus New York City over the
city's absolute ban on stun guns. These
are non-lethal weapons. You would think
this would be an easy case to win for
the second amendment given the fact in
the year of our lord 2016
with a supreme court that included like
I don't know Ruth Bader Ginsburg
not exactly a fan of the second
amendment that found that stun guns are
arms under the second amendment and then
remanded the case back down to the
Massachusetts Supreme Court to get it
right. at which point the Massachusetts
Supreme Court did indeed find that stun
guns were protected arms under the
Second Amendment and dismissed the
criminal case against the woman Jaime
Kitano who had used a stun gun to defend
herself against an ex-boyfriend that was
threatening her according to her. And
she used it in Massachusetts even though
it was a banned weapon in Massachusetts.
That was in 2016. Well, apparently it's
not going to be that easy. Who would
have guessed that in New York City
federal judges could not follow Supreme
Court president even though they are the
inferior courts? It's not my language.
That's the language of the United States
Constitution in Article 3 that talks
about the Supreme Court and any inferior
courts, inferior courts created by the
Congress. And that is exactly what the
United States Court of Appeals for the
Second Circuit in New York is an
inferior court as are the federal
district courts in New York. With that
said, this argument just occurred
because the district court judge found
that guess what? Essentially found by
implication that stun guns are not
protected arms on the second amendment.
And they didn't even need to bother to
analyze the second amendment question.
How did the district court do that?
Well, you know, the usual stuff. They
basically elevated the incom use test,
which is part of history. We'll get to
that in a moment. They elevated the in
common use test to the plain text level
and said as I predicted the anti-guners
would do that the burden is on the
burden is on the second amendment rights
claimants in this case the plaintiffs
arguing that stun guns should be
protected. The court found that the
plaintiffs defending the Second
Amendment, arguing for the Second
Amendment, attacking the stun gun ban in
New York City, that they bore the burden
to showing that stun guns were in common
use by Americans for lawful purposes for
self-defense.
That is 100% wrong. That is 100%
nonsense.
And it is only embraced by, in my
opinion, disingenuous
judges that simply don't like the idea
of Americans having guns because they
are surrounded by armed security in
marble halls.
That's right. We are the peasants. We
don't need guns. We don't need weapons.
We can call 911 cuz we have a US marshal
standing out front like judges do. Haha.
Anyway, this is obviously wrong and they
know it's wrong, but they don't care
because they know the Supreme Court can
only take one or two Second Amendment
cases a year to spank them because the
Supreme Court has a lot of other major
cases involving other areas of American
law outside of the context of the Second
Amendment. So here in the CC versus city
of New York case after the district
court judge dismissed this case claiming
that stun guns are not protected arms
under the second amendment because the
plaintiffs the ci the second amendment
rights claimments had failed to
demonstrate
that these arms are in common use. Now,
of course, this went up to an appeal uh
to the US Court of Appeals for the
Second Circuit in front of a three judge
panel involving Judge Ray Lawyer, who
believe it or not, actually helped hire
me many years ago when I was a young
judicial intern back in the day for
Judge Robert P. Patterson in the United
States District Court for the Southern
District of New York. That was a bunch
of years ago when Ray was a law clerk,
very nice guy. I really liked working
with him. and I was simply a law student
out of NYU. We were both NYU's guys.
Nevertheless, Ray Lawyer went from Ray
Lyair, my law clerk boss, to the United
States Court of Hills for the second
circuit and a judge, the honorable, and
now he's a feeder judge to the left-wing
justices on the Supreme Court like
Justice Sodomayor, Justice Kagan,
Justice Brown Jackson, you get the
drill. So with that said, Judge Ray Ly
here was not only on this case at
Councy, but he was also on an earlier
case from several months ago called
Gomez versus the United States. Now, the
Gomez case, uh, which Judge Lawyer was
on, was also on with Judge Dennis
Jacobs, another, you know, great guy.
Uh, so I really like them. Um, always
had good experiences with both of them
in my time. Uh, but unfortunately, they
don't necessarily nail it when it comes
to the Second Amendment. Just my that's
just my take. And I don't think the
Supreme Court is going to be eye to eye
or see eye to eye with any of them. But
nevertheless, here is the world we live
in. So in the United States versus Gomez
case several months ago, they again said
that the uh arm at issue was not
protected under the plain text of the
second amendment. They had all this
analysis and then today in the calcy
case during or argument they basically
indicated the three judge panel
indicated that they were going to
embrace the Gomez standard for what
constitutes a protected arm and all of
that mishagosh all that work uh legal
analysis has to take place at the plain
text level. Now we've gone over this and
if you've been following the four boxes
diner you know exactly what I'm going to
say. The anti-gun movement in America is
desperate, is absolutely desperate to
elevate every single issue involving the
Second Amendment analysis. What is the
plain text? What is in common use? What
is dangerous and unusual? They must must
elevate all those questions and where
you resolve those questions to the step
one part of brein at the plain text
level. Why? Because at the plain text
level, the burden of proof is on the
Second Amendment rights claimant. It's
on either the plaintiff suing the
government for Second Amendment rights
or it's on the criminal defendant
asserting a Second Amendment defense to
the crime. But they want everything to
be at the plain text level because at
the plain text level, the burden of
proof has not yet shifted to the
government. The way of course the brewin
methodology works which is essentially
the Heler methodology put it put
together in a paint by numbers fashion.
Bruin and Heler are the same
methodology. It's just brewin is more
explicit. So the lower courts could not
mess it up and yet many of them still
do. Again once the plain text of the
second amendment covers the relevant
conduct of the second amendment rights
claimment. In this case I want to carry
a stun gun in New York City. Once the
plane text is implicated by that
conduct, the burn shifts to the
government here in New York City to
demonstrate. There's a historical
tradition of prohibiting stun guns
from being possessed by Americans. And
that is simply not possible. Once the
burden shifts to the city of New York,
once the burden shifts to the government
to show that stun guns are dangerous and
unusual, they cannot do it. And that is
exactly why every one of these anti-gun
courts, I'm sorry, they are. It's just
objectively true in my view, right? The
second circuit, the fourth circuit, the
seventh circuit out of Chicago, the
Ninth Circuit out of San Francisco, all
the usual suspect terrible jurisdictions
when it comes to the right to keep and
bear arms, all of them
elevate
the income use inquiry to the plain text
level because it helps the government
win.
But that's not what the Supreme Court
has ever said because remember the in
common use test by Americans for lawful
purposes. That test comes from where? It
comes from the historical tradition of
one kind of gun regulation. It comes as
Heler explains in detail the historical
tradition in an arms band case that's
relevant derives from the historical
tradition of the prohibition of the
carrying of dangerous and unusual
weapons
which means that it comes from history.
You're dealing with history. Because
you're dealing with history, guess what?
It arises in step two of brewing where
the burden is on the government to
demonstrate a historical tradition of
firearms regulation that justifies what
your regulation does. And if you're
trying to ban a particular kind of arm,
which a stun gun obviously is, then the
burn is on the government to show that
those stun guns are dangerous and
unusual, which means by definition the
government bears the burden to show that
those arms are not in common use by
Americans for lawful purposes. Because
if they are in common use, they cannot
by definition be unusual and thus they
cannot be dangerous and unusual.
And yet these anti-gun district courts,
these anti-gun courts of appeals pretend
that the incoming use test is part of
the plain text. That is utterly BS.
the only only connection
to history
and the plain text of the second
amendment which as you know reads the
right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed.
when they refer to that text
must be informed by history.
All that means as the Supreme Court's
analysis demonstrates
is that when you go to define what does
well regulated mean, what does militia
mean, what does the people mean, what
does the the what does to keep mean,
what does to bear mean, what does arm
mean?
is that you use definitions
from the time the 1791
Bill of Rights was written.
So if there's a disconnect between the
modern day definition of militia, the
modern-day definition of arms, the
modern day definition of to keep or to
bear, if there is a distinction between
the 21st century definition of those
words, and the 1791 definition of those
words, you lock in the definition
according to history in 1791. That is
when they say that history informs the
text of the second amendment. It locks
in the time period. You look for the
definitions of those words. And that is
why in the Supreme Court's decision in
Heler, they looked at dictionaries
prepared by lexographers. Lexographers
is a really fun word that simply means
people that are so nerdy in life that
they are actually compilers of
dictionaries. So you looked at Samuel
Johnson, a lexographer in England who
put together an English dictionary in
England. And then you look at Noah
Webster who was an American lexographer
who put together an American dictionary
of American English in America and some
others like that. But they did it at the
time of the founding to make sure that
the words of the Second Amendment were
understood when they were written. No
different than if you and I write a
contract this week and 10 years from now
there's a question about the contract.
They go back in time to today to say,
"What did Mark and you think when you
wrote the contract today in 2026?"
That's what they would ask 20 years from
now or 10 years from now whenever if
there's a question about what is the
contract or the trust or the will mean
they go back to the time it was entered
into when the constitution the bill of
rights was entered into in the 18th
century that's what you look for but
what's going on here is the historical
tradition when you're dealing with an
armsb case of income use derived from
dangerous and unusual they are elevating
that these anti-gun courts including the
second circuit in the Gomez case uh with
a panel of judge lawyer and judge Jacob
OBS both good guys. But I'm sorry they
got it wrong. They did in my view.
They've elevated the incom use test to
the plain text.
No, no, no. Supreme Court's not going to
allow that. And here's the interesting
thing. The second circuit is in a dicey
position right now. And I bet they know
it because if they write this opinion in
the Ky versus City of New York case in a
way, and by the way, there's 0% chance
the Second Amendment rights claimments
are going to win the Second Circuit.
They are 100% going to lose this case.
100% going to lose this case. It will be
three to zero in favor of the city of
New York over the Second Amendment
rights claimants in this Calcy versus
City of New York case. That's the
decision. That's very very very
dangerous for the anti-gunners because
the Supreme Court already in the Kitano
case in 2016 which is a much worse court
for the second amendment than it is
today
in an 8 to zero percurium decision and
Kaitano just sumearily reversed in like
two pages the stun gun ban of the of the
state of Massachusetts. This is the
Massachusetts Supreme Court's decision.
So, if the Second Circuit does what I'm
pretty confident they're going to do
here,
they are going to say essentially
implicitly or otherwise, they may try to
fudge it, but they're basically going to
hold implicitly, if not expressly, that
stun guns in this particular case are
not protected arms in the Second
Amendment. They're going to have a bunch
of reasons why that's the case. They're
going to try to dodge the question. And
the reason why they're going to write
this opinion in kind of a squirrely way,
you mark my words. This opinion that
rules against the Second Amendment is
going to be really, really squirrely and
narrowly fa tailored and they're going
to have all these kind of weird things
in it. And it's going to be for a single
purpose. They're going to write this
opinion desperate that the Supreme Court
doesn't reach out and touch them by
granting cir and sumearily reversing
them with a per curium decision that
basically with the back of the hand
swats the second circuit and says you
guys got this so wrong. We're going to
dismiss this and tell you to get it
right in like two pages. Just like we
spanked the Massachusetts Supreme Court
in Kantano, we're going to do the same
to you. And I have very little doubt
that the law clerks and the people
working on this case are looking at each
other right now over the uh over the
second circuit lunch table there saying
to ourselves, "How on earth are we going
to write this opinion that minimizes the
risk of the US Supreme Court spanking us
in a terribly embarrassing way?" Because
if we say that stun guns are not arms,
forget protected arms, we just say
they're not arms under the plain text of
the Second Amendment in light of the
Supreme Court president of Kaitano, we
are simply going to be asking for big-
time trouble. And by the way, if you
think about the word dangerous, just
step for side moment. Remember the the
tradition, the historical tradition is
dangerous and unusual. We spend most of
our time dealing with unusual because
the reality is when you're fighting
about magazines that hold more than 10
rounds, when you're fighting about
semi-automatic rifles, when you're
fighting about revolvers, all these
things, THESE ARE UBIQUITOUS. THEY'RE
EVERYWHERE. There's no debate that these
things are in common use by Americans
for lawful purposes, which includes just
possessing them. Doesn't have to be for
self-defense. Just owning them is a
lawful purpose. That's enough for common
use. So, we just have it in common use
because if we win in common use, we win.
It's sufficient to win these arms banan
cases. But let's just pause for a moment
and look at the other part of that
conjunction. Dangerous and unusual.
Let's assume for the sake of argument
that a stun gun is unusual, which is
not, but let's assume it is. The
anti-gutter still cannot win. Why?
We know that whatever dangerous and
unusual means, the word dangerous cannot
mean simply a firearm that shoots
bullets that can kill people because in
Heler in 2008 we had a decision that
says that handguns were not dangerous
and unusual and could not be banned. So
even assuming that the second circuit
Gomez case that judge lawyer and judge
Jacobs among others were on and this
Kelsey case says well you know the
plaintiffs that support the second
amendment failed to establish that stun
guns are in common use. It doesn't
matter because by definition those stun
guns are not dangerous
and therefore the stun guns cannot be
dangerous and unusual because they're
not dangerous as that term is understood
by the Supreme Court. So either way the
second amendment rights claimants should
win this case but they 100% are going to
lose this case at the US Court appeals
for the second circuit level. And the
question is, can that court somehow
dodge the possibility of getting smashed
in a very embarrassing way by the
Supreme Court? Because if the Supreme
Court doesn't like what they do, it will
be an embarrassing reversal in a
summarial in a in a summary fashion. It
will not look good for that court. And I
am confident that in the back of their
minds right now, they fear that and thus
are trying to figure out a way to write
that opinion in as narrow and quirky way
as possible to dodge that exact outcome,
which would be quite embarrassing to all
the members of the Second Circuit.
Anyway, there you have it. That's my
take on this. Uh we'll let you know when
there's a decision. I'm sure it be many
months from now, but that's kind of the
lay of the land. Uh with that said, I
appreciate you all tuning in today. Uh,
make sure you follow me over there on
X4box.
We have almost 30,000 followers. So, if
you can help me get over that hump,
that'd be awesome. Uh, don't forget to
subscribe both to YouTube and to Rumble
here. And I'll talk to all of you again
real soon here at the Warbox Box Diner.
Orders up. Table 2A.